Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Getscher. Ich bin die Dienstabendärztin auf dieser Station.
Ich werde mit Ihnen das Erstgespräch führen.
Zunächst werde ich Ihnen einige Fragen zu Ihren persönlichen Daten stellen.
Danach werden wir Ihre Akteuren besprechen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Anton Stein.
Anton Stein. Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam bestabieren?
Natürlich A wie Anton, N wie Nordpol, T wie Theodor, O wie Otto, N wie Nordpol.
Und dann nachnamens Stein, wieder Stein.
Okay. Okay, Herr Stein, alles klar.
Und wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 74 Jahre alt.
74. Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 22. August 1951.
51. Okay. Herr Stein, wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit?
Ich wiege momentan circa 95 Kilogramm.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1 Meter 75 groß.
75 groß. Okay, alles klar.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihr Hausärztin?
Dr. Schmidt.
Dr. Herr Schmidt oder Frau Schmidt?
Frau Schmidt.
Okay. Danke schön.
Herr Stein, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Was führt Sie heute zu uns?
Ich komme heute zu Ihnen, weil ich extreme Luftnot habe.
Luftnot?
Das macht mir sehr zu schaffen.
Ich habe das so noch nie gehabt.
Okay, ersten Mal.
Und seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ich habe diese Beschwerden schon seit knapp zwei Wochen.
Die werden aber immer schlimmer.
Okay, okay, okay.
Könnten Sie bitte Atemnot ganz genau beschreiben?
Ja, also am Anfang hatte ich wirklich nur Beschwerden,
als ich die Treppen hochgegangen bin.
Oder wenn ich einkaufen war.
Aber mittlerweile habe ich die Beschwerden,
auch wenn ich kleinste Bewegung mache.
Okay, okay. Im Ruhe haben Sie auch diese Beschwerden?
Ein Ruhe.
Mittlerweile fast auch, ja.
Okay, haben Sie auch Brustschmerzen oder enge Gefühle?
Ich habe kein enge Gefühl, aber wenn ich mich sehr belaste, dann schon.
Okay, okay, kein enge Gefühl.
Aber ist es eher eine Luftnot?
Okay, ja.
Und Herr Stein, jetzt möchte ich ein bisschen kurz unterbrechen.
Ich möchte zuerst Ihre Witzartparameter missen.
Danach können wir diese Besprechung weitermachen.
Ja, dann.
Okay.
Ja, und ich werde Ihnen mit Naseulkanüle Sauerstoff geben.
Ja, wie fühlen Sie sich jetzt?
Danke, es geht besser.
Okay, okay, alles klar.
Könnten wir weitersprechen?
Ja, bitte.
Okay, okay.
Herr Stein, haben Sie begleitzende Symptome?
Wie husten?
Nein.
Nein, nur Atemnot.
Atemnot, ganz genau.
Haben Sie vor zwei Wochen Erkältung oder Halsschmerzen, Kopfschmerzen?
Nein.
Nein, keine.
Und jetzt?
In den Reifen zwei Wochen?
Immer noch nicht.
Okay, leiden Sie unser Übelkeit, Erbrochen?
Nein.
Erbrechen?
Okay.
Haben Sie ... ja, Sie haben keine Brustschmerzen, oder?
Nicht wirklich.
Wenn ich jetzt treppe, hoch steige manchmal, weil ich viel atme und muss habe, ich
habe schon Schmerzen, glaube ich.
Aber das ist jetzt keine richtiger Torachschmerz, also Brustschmerzen.
Okay.
Haben Sie in Ihrer Beine ... oder haben Sie geschwollene Beine?
Ja, seit vier, fünf Tagen habe ich geschwollene Beine.
Okay, vier, fünf Tagen?
Ungefähr, ja.
Ja, okay, seit vier, fünf Tagen.
Und was geschwollene?
Und gibt es Schmerz?
Nein.
Nein, nur Schwellungen?
Immer.
Und stehen diese Schwellungen zum ersten Mal oder früher haben Sie schon mal
gehabt?
Ich habe diese zum ersten Mal.
Erst mal, okay.
Ich schwollene Beine.
Und gibt es kaltliche Empfindigkeiten, kaltige Gefühlschuldigung?
Haben Sie kaltige Gefühle in Beinen?
Farbeveränderungen?
Wie bleuliche Farbeveränderungen?
Okay.
Haben Sie oder leiten Sie an einer kröntischen Erkrankung, wie Herzerkrankungen, Lungenerkrankungen?
Also ich habe eine Guttmusstörung.
Ich habe Vorhoffelmann.
Vorhoffelmann, okay.
Ich habe auch Bluthochdruck.
Und ich habe auch eine erhöhte Cholestrinwert.
Okay.
Seit wann leiten Sie an dieser Krankheit?
Das habe ich jetzt seit ungefähr acht Jahren.
Erholt der Blutwerte oder welche?
Ja, das wurde alles zusammen festgestellt.
Ah, okay, okay.
Ungefähr acht Jahren, oder?
Okay.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie regelmäßig ein?
Also ich nehme Hamiprilein, fünf Medikamente, morgens einmal.
Fünf Medikamente.
Morgens?
Einmal.
M-hm.
Dann nehme ich Atovastatin ein, 20 Milligramm, abends.
Abends, okay.
Ich nehme auch Bisoprolol ein, fünf Milligramm.
Okay.
Und ich nehme Apixaban ein, morgens und abends.
Saban.
Wissen Sie, wie die Dosierung?
Fünf Milligramm.
Fünf Milligramm Apixaban und morgens oder?
Beides, morgens und abends.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie diese Medikamente regelmäßig ein?
Eigentlich schon, ja, aber ich habe in der letzten Zeit ein wenig nicht regelmäßig
eingenommen, unregelmäßig.
Ah, okay.
Gibt es bestimmte ... Warum nehmen Sie nichts regelmäßig ein?
Die Medikamente sieht sehr wichtig.
Ja, ich weiß, aber ich habe ...
Ich habe sie vergessen, ich war im Urlaub, da habe ich vergessen.
Und dann ...
M-hm.
Okay, alles klar, ich verstehe.
Ich möchte wissen, ob Sie die beiden Beinen diese Schwellungen haben?
Nur einseitig oder beidseitig.
Und stehen diese Schwellungen gleichzeitig oder ...
Gleichzeitig.
Okay.
Und gibt es diese Schwellungen in Ihrer Füße auf?
In Ihrer Füße?
Nur die Unterschenkel.
Nur Unterschenkel, okay.
Und gibt es keine Farbeveränderungen, keine Rötungen?
Oder leuliche Farbeveränderungen?
Neues.
Neues, okay.
Und Unterschenkel.
Okay, alles klar.
Ja, Herr Stein, jetzt möchte ich Ihre allgemeine medizinische Zustands fragen.
Haben Sie Fieber, Nachtschweiß oder Schutelfrost?
Nein.
Nein, okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Masse lassen oder Sturrgang?
Auch nicht.
Okay, prima.
Hat sich Ihr Appetit oder Ihr Gewicht in letzter Zeit verändert?
Ich habe zugenommen.
Ich habe circa 5-6 kg zugenommen.
5-6 kg?
Okay, 5-6 kg zugenommen.
In welcher Zeitraum haben Sie zugenommen?
Also in den letzten 3 Wochen.
Okay.
Letztem 3 Wochen.
Hat sich Ihr Appetit verändert?
Vielleicht ein bisschen weniger Appetit, aber sonst normalerweise.
Okay, weniger.
Weniger vermerzt Ihr Ihre Appetit?
Ich würde sagen gleich.
Gleicher, okay.
Herr Stein, wie ist Ihr Schlaf in letzter Zeit?
Schlecht, schlecht, weil ich ...
Schlecht.
... wegen dieser Beschwerden?
Ja, aber auch in der Nacht, manchmal Luftnot.
Und dann habe ich Probleme einzuschlafen.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie besonders in der Nacht
schlecht Luftnot haben, richtig?
Nein, ich habe besonders viel Luftnot, wenn ich mich bewege.
Okay.
Aber ich habe auch nachts Luftnot.
Okay, brauchen Sie in der Nacht viele Kisten?
Ja, wir sind 4-5 Tage nämlich 2 Kisten.
4-5 Tage 2 Kisten.
Okay.
Moment.
Brauchen Sie in der Nacht viel Luft?
Und deswegen möchten Sie aufstehen und tief einatmen?
Ja, kommt vor.
Ja?
Mhm, ist klar.
Sie haben keinen Husten, richtig verstanden?
Selten, manchmal schon.
Okay, selten.
Und könnten Sie bitte beschreiben, selten, was meinen Sie?
Wie bitte?
Was meinen Sie damit?
Seltenen Husten zum Beispiel?
Manchmal, ab und zu habe ich Husten, aber hust ich.
Jetzt alle 10 Minuten oder so, ab und zu.
Und für alle 10 Minuten.
Ist das also ein Hustenreiz?
Bitte?
Eine Hustenreiz habe ich.
Hustenreiz, was meinen Sie, damit ich nicht verstehe?
Entschuldigung.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich nicht husten muss.
Okay, okay, alles klar.
Haben Sie Herzrasen oder Herzstolpern?
Ja.
Seit ungefähr 2 Wochen?
Ne, seit 8 Jahren.
Okay, seit Vorausliebern?
Richtig, genau.
Haben diese Medikamente nicht geholfen?
Doch, eigentlich helfen die.
Aber trotz, fühlen Sie diese Probleme.
Herr Stein, haben Sie in letzter Zeit Stress?
Ne, ich war jetzt vor 3 Wochen im Urlaub.
Eigentlich geht es mir gut.
Sehr gut, okay.
Und trainieren Sie regelmäßig?
Bitte?
Machen Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ich fahre Fahrrad, ich gehe spazieren.
Okay.
Ich bin ja nicht der Ehrgustin, ne?
Okay, nun hätte ich einige Fragen zu Genuspezialen, Herr Stein.
Rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche nicht.
Okay, haben Sie früher geraucht?
Nein.
Okay, prima.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Manchmal, bei Feiern, wenn es eine Feier gibt.
Feiern, was trinken Sie gerne?
Bier, Wein.
Und wie viel Flasche oder Gläschen?
Kann ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Kommt darauf an.
Bitte?
Es kommt darauf an.
Okay, alles klar.
Nehmen Sie Drogen, Herr Stein?
Ich bin 74 Jahre alt, ich nehme keine Drogen ein.
Mit 74?
Ja, okay, okay.
Alles klar.
Herr Stein, haben Sie Allergie oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Nein.
Nein, okay, prima.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie Kronsche Erkrankungen?
Wie Bluthochdruck?
Ja, meine Schwester hat das auch.
Bluthochdruck.
Welche Erkrankungen?
Die Eltern sind beide gestorben.
Okay, ist mir sehr erleiht Herr Stein.
Hatten Sie Kronsche Erkrankungen?
Ja.
Also, weiß ich nicht mehr.
Okay, okay.
Warum sind Sie verstorben?
Lassen Sie?
Mein Vater ist damals im Krieg gestorben.
Er ist jetzt in der Flasche.
Meine Mutter hat keinen Schlaganfall gehabt.
Okay, okay.
Unser Schlaganfall.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Ich habe gesagt, eine Schwester.
Eine Schwester, sind Sie gesund?
Ich habe gesagt, sie hat auch Blutdruck.
Blutdruck, okay.
Alles klar.
Was waren Sie von Beruf?
Ich war damals Lkw-Fahrer.
Lkw-Fahrer.
Und jetzt sind Sie in Renta gegangen.
Ja.
Alles klar.
Und wie ist Ihre Wohnsituation?
Leben Sie allein oder gibt es andere?
Ich lebe mit meiner Frau zusammen.
Okay, immer.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben zwei Töchter.
Zwei Töchter.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja.
Herr Stein, sind Sie geimpft?
Ja, mein Haushalt hat das noch überprüft.
Okay, gegen COVID-19.
Gegen COVID bin ich nicht geimpft.
Nein, also jetzt nicht geimpft.
Aber ich habe mich damals in der Corona-Zeit geimpft.
Ah, okay.
Nicht auf, für dich schon.
Die letzte war vor zwei Jahren.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit eine Reise gemacht?
Ja, ich war im Urlaub gewesen vor drei Wochen.
Vor drei Wochen.
Wo sind Sie gegangen?
Ich war in Holland.
Wo ist diese Stadt genau?
Ich glaube nicht.
Holland, am Meer.
Am Meer, okay.
Holland, Niederlande.
Okay, okay.
Ich verstehe jetzt.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie ähnliche Beschwerden
oder Husten, Fieber?
Ich habe ja keinen Fieber Husten.
Ja, ich weiß.
In Ihrer Familie, zum Beispiel Frauen nicht.
Herr Stein,
gibt es in Ihrer Bauchsschwerung
auch oder?
Nein, okay.
Nur die Beinen.
Jetzt muss ich kurz gucken, ob
alle Informationen richtig sind.
Und ja, jetzt möchte ich
kurz zusammenfassen.
Seit zwei Wochen haben Sie
starke Atemnot, besonders
bestehen diese Beschwerden,
Treppen, Hossteigen und bei Bewegung.
Aber seit vier, fünf Tagen
sind diese Beschwerden stärker geworden.
Außerdem haben Sie
geschwollene Beinen, aber ohne Schmerzen,
ohne Farbeveränderungen.
Und seit vier, fünf Tagen
brauchen Sie auch in der Nacht
viele Kisten beim Schlafen.
Okay, okay.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen
oder fragen an mich?
Nein.
Okay, jetzt werde ich Sie
körperlich unterhalten.
Danach werde ich Ihre Vitalparameter
noch mal messen und Blut abnehmen.
Wir brauchen einige
operative Maßnahmen.
Wir brauchen einige operative Maßnahmen.
Zum Beispiel Röntgen-Torax,
ja genau und gegebenen
Fais-Computer-Tomography.
Wenn wir alle Ergebnisse zusammengetragen haben,
werden wir mit einander noch mal sprechen.
Legen Sie sich die
Fragen hin, ich komme gleich.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Oder Ergänzung?
Ich denke alle Fragen sind gestartet.
Der Detaillierteil ist durchgeführt.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Bitte schön.
Herr Stein, gibt es in
Ihrer krankischen Erkrankung
seine Mutter?
Weiß ich nicht mehr.
Woran ist gestorben?
Hab ich gesagt, Schlaganfall.
Entschuldigung, Ihre Vater, woran gestorben?
Hab ich gesagt, Krieg, im Krieg.
2 Fragen, Kollegen, 2 Fragen.
Danke.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Haben Sie sich viele Probleme unter Funktionen?
Oder über Funktionen?
Gute Frage, nein.
Danke. Darf ich fragen?
Bitte schön.
Haben Sie stuhlprobleme?
Nein, habe ich auch nicht.
Ich habe andere Fragen.
Haben Sie eine hohe Blutfett?
Oder ein kolesteroles Problem?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Blutfett.
Hab ich gesagt, Schabu,
ich habe eine hohe kolesterole Inverter.
Danke. Hab ich gesagt.
Seit wann haben Sie?
Hab ich gesagt, seit 8 Jahren. Danke.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit dafür?
Natürlich.
Es handelt sich um Herrn Anton Stein,
einen 74-Jährigen-Patienten.
Er stellte sich heute wegen seit 2 Wochen
bestehender Barschein
und hat sich mit einer Beziehung
über eine Beziehung geholfen.
Er hat 2 Wochen bestehender Düsbne bei uns vor.
Er hat diese Beschwerden zum 1. Mal
besonders verschlechtert
Düsbne sich beim Treppen
hochsteigen und bei Bewegung.
Außer dem klackte er
seit 4-5 Tagen
ödeme in beide Beinen
und er hat sich mit einer Beziehung
über die Beine beschrieben.
Er hat die Beine beschrieben
und hat sich mit einer Beziehung
mit einer Beine beschrieben.
Keine Füße oder andere Körperteile.
Er hat die Frage nach
Engegefühlen, Torexschmerzen,
Angina, Entschuldigung, Angina,
Torexschmerzen wurden verneint
und er hatte keine Emesis oder Nausea.
Interessant ist,
dass er seit 4-5 Tagen
Orthopne und Paroxysmal
nächtliche Düsbne auch
hat.
Ja, hat.
Die vegetative Anamnese
ergab
ein Gewichtsuname
in der Reipfung
in der Reipfung letzten 3 Wochen
5-6 Kilogramm
und wegen dieser Beschwerden
ist sein Schlaf
schlecht wegen nächtlicher Düsbne.
Er hat kein Husten
er ist schwach
und ist nicht ein Husten
Er ist schwach
und ist ein Husten
Normalerweise trainiert er regelmäßig
Fahrradfahren und Spazieren gehen
Er klagte über
seit 8 Jahren
Tachikardi
und Extrasystolen
wegen seiner
Arteriellpibrillation
Vorhofflemann
Vor 8 Jahren
bei ihm ein Vorhofflemann Diagnose
festgestellt
Er klagte über 8 Jahre über Extrasystolen
Vorhofflemann
Diese Diagnose
wurde bei ihm festgestellt
Aber er hat
Herzrasen und Herzstolpern
Tachikardi
Er hat solche Beschrieben
Außerdem leidet er an einer
Arteriellenhypertonie
seit 8 Jahren
Er nimmt er
5 mg morgens
Atorvastatin 20 mg
Abends bis Oprolol 5 mg
und Apixaban 5 mg morgens
und abends
Aber in letzter Zeit
hat er diese Medikamente nicht regelmäßig
eingenommen
Das ist nicht gut
Und Drogen und Nikotin konsum wurden verneint
Er trinkt gelegentlich Alkohol
nur bei der Feiern
Bier oder Wein
Und er war sehr gelegentlich
Familienanamnistisch
gab mutterlicherseits
Apopleks
Seine Schwester leidet an einer
Arteriellenhypertonie auch
Sein Vater ist wegen einer Krieg
verstorben
Er kennt nicht genau, welche Krankheiten er hat
Er war in Krieg gestorben
Er war Lkw-Fahrer
und jetzt ist er Rente gegangen
Er wohnt mit seiner Frau zusammen
Er hat 2 gesunde Kinder
Er ist vorständig geimpft
Aber sein Covid-19-Aufrichtungen
vor 2 Jahren machen lassen
Und vor 3 Wochen
hat er nach Holland gezogen
Er ist vor 2 Jahren geimpft
Aber vor 3 Wochen
hat er nach Holland
eine Reise gemacht
Wir beschwerden
seit 2 Wochen bestehenden Dyspne
Und Orthopne
prox. nächtliche
Dyspne sprechen für
einen Lungenembolie
wegen einer TV-T hin
Differenzialdiagnostisch kommen
Ein Herzinsuffizienz
und chronische Branche
um eine Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen
werde ich
Wettzeilfache Meter messen
danach Blut abnehmen
und werde ich den Patientin
körperlich untersuchen
Und ja
Apparativdiagnostisch brauche ich
Brachen wir
Röntgen
Torax Computer-Tomografie
mit Kontrastmittel
und Sonografie
in beide Beinen
Wie so
glauben Sie einen Lungenembolie
Er
leidet an
einer Vorhoffliman
und er nimmt
sein Medikament nicht regelmäßig ein
Das ist sehr stärker Risikofaktörer
für die Embolie
Er hat beide Beine
Schwellungen
Eine TVT meistens in beiden Beinen
oder in einem Bein? Nein, eigentlich das
sprechen gegen eine CVT
Aber
Vorhoffliman
uns unregelmäßige Medikamente einnehmen
Einnahme sprechen für CVT
ist nicht klar
Deswegen brauchen wir auf jeden Fall
CVT auszuschließen oder bestätigen
Sie haben gesagt, differenzialen Diagnostisch
könnte es eine Herzinsuffizienz sein
Ist das nicht wahrscheinlicher,
dass er eine Herzinsuffizienz hat?
Ja, es kann sein
Er hat viele Risikofaktören
für die Herzinsuffizienz
Er hat paroxysmal nächtliche Dyspne
und Orthopne
in der Zeit 4-5 Tagen
Deswegen sollten wir
Herzinsuffizienz bestätigen
oder kontrollieren
Eine TVT- und Lungenembolie
ist eher unwahrscheinlich
Aber es ist eine gute differenzial Diagnose
Beschwerden, die er hat
und deuten am ehesten für eine Herzinsuffizienz an
Er beschreibt ja auch, dass er Gewicht zugenommen hat
Genau, Sie haben recht
Bei einer TVT hat man normalerweise
keine Gewichtszunahme
Und bei einer Lungenembolie
hat man normalerweise keine Gewichtszunahme
Ja, Sie haben recht
Wenn Sie jetzt ein Röntgenbild machen
Was erwarten Sie? Was würden Sie sehen im Röntgenbild?
Wegen dieser Dyspne
kontrollieren wir
ob Fremdkörper oder
Nicht Fremdkörper
Aber man guckt, ob er ein großes Herz hat
Ob er eventuell Pleureregüsse hat
Er hat ja auch Dyspne
Das muss man nachschauen
Und im Labor sollten Sie ein Parameter ganz wichtig bestimmen
Wie heißt dieser Parameter?
Pro BMP
Was sagt uns dieser Parameter?
Diese Parameter
zeigt uns
Herzmuskelschädigung
Nicht unbedingt Schädigung
Erweiterung, wenn das Herz
Erweiterung ist
Aber ich habe noch eine Frage
Sie haben uns ja im Jahr vorruf, Lehmann
Haben Sie den Patienten gefragt, ob schon mal eine Herzkathete
Untersuchung gemacht wurde? Nein, nein
Ich habe diese Frage nicht gestellt
Man muss auf jeden Fall stellen
Das ist eine Frage, die die Patienten schon mal
eine Herzkathete-Untersuchung hatte
Das sollten Sie auf jeden Fall noch mal nachfragen
Wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass der Patient
jetzt eine globale Herzinsuffiziehens hat
mit Pleureregüssen, mit Unterschenkeldämen
Wie würden Sie diesen Patienten therapieren?
Ich würde zum
ersten Mal die Urätikum
verschreiben
und Sauerstoffsättigungswerte
kontrollieren
Therapie, nicht Diagnostik
Geben, ja
Sauerstoff geben ist sehr wichtig
in diesem Patient
Die Diagnostik
um Bluthoffdruck
Artiliellerhypertonie zu kontrollieren
oder kontrollieren würde ich
Artiliellerhypertonie kontrollieren
und sein
Vorhoffniemann
mit anticoagularen
Medikamente
Er hatte ja bereits Anticoagulare als Therapie
Er hatte Apixaban
Aber gegen den Vorhoffniemann
und der Herzinsuffiziehens
müssen Sie was machen? Sie müssen die Herzrequenz kontrollieren
Genau, genau
Sie müssen eine Frequenzlimitierung machen
Ja
Wenn es z.B.körer kann sein
Genau, denn ein Tachiarhythmie
kann immer zu einer Herzinsuffiziehens führen
Der Patient hat gesagt
dass er seine Medikamente vergessen hat
Vielleicht nimmt er den Betablokker nicht ein
Das wissen wir nicht
Sie fragen können, welche Medikamente er vergessen hat
z.B.
Aber wichtig ist Diolidische Therapie
und Frequenzlimitierung auf jeden Fall
Was sollte man noch machen?
Was sollte man machen?
Ein CT
CT, Rundskern
Eine Echokardiografie
Eine Ultraschall vom Herzen
Echokardiografie
Genau, Echokardiografie
Danke schön
Würden Sie den Patienten nach Hause lassen
oder ein Stationär aufnehmen? Nein, ich würde
diesen Patienten ein Stationär aufnehmen
einen Zugang legen und ein cardiologisches Konsil anfordern
Ja